all right Janine Janine where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
um I was born in Jacksonville Florida
and I lived there until I was about
14 13 14.
then I moved to South Florida from Tampa
and then South Florida for a couple of
years and then back to Florida what was
your family like
well when I was young they had a lot of
money and were kind of society people
and then
my dad was in real estate and my mom was
a stay-at-home mom and
then my brother just kind of went
off the deep end with drugs and alcohol
very young
and when he was 15 and didn't come home
on a Saturday morning until after Dawn
my dad he had a blowout fight
I was nine years old my brother he was
15.
and so
my my dad gave my mom an ultimatum
either my brother left or he left
because no interventions were working
and my mom decided that he had to go and
my dad was an angry man I mean he could
I've seen him throw my mom up against
the refrigerator during fights you know
because he would drink a lot they both
did
and so in 1976 he left
and
um
they had like a three-year War it was
horrific
um I've
while I was in school in the seventh
grade my mom called
my sister and I out of school we were in
a private school
because it turned out well she said that
my father had hired a Hitman to kill her
and that he was going to abduct us and
so we went to a Days Inn and spent a
week there scared to death
not you know couldn't look above the
windows for fear that we were going to
get shot
and
um at the end of all of that years later
when I got to know my father because we
were estranged from him for many years
when I was in college he would take me
to dinner at The Brown Derby at the
University when I went to school at the
University of Florida in Gainesville and
it took a lot of me asking and drilling
questions but finally I believed him it
turns out my mom had gone to a bar and
met a man and
wanted to hire him to kill my dad and a
police officer who was undercover
overheard the conversation
and so
my dad was in his beach condo in
Jacksonville
and a detective called him and said
Somebody's coming to your door
don't answer it unless we give you a
phone call telling you it's one of our
people and before he knew it he had
three detectives in his apartment or his
condominium
and they watched this man come up to the
door pause
I guess think about it turn around and
walk away he did that twice and I guess
his gut told him not to knock on that
door
so I guess they never caught the guy but
um obviously my mother had lied to us
and traumatized us to cover herself
um
so it we ended up in the ghetto
and we lived in South Beach for a couple
of years when it was still very much a
ghetto between 81 and 83.
where I lived was later turned into the
police station in South Beach
um but in the time I was there despite
spending time hanging out on the street
with my sister and another friend and my
sister getting caught up in drugs and
being a victim of pedophilia which today
on we can reflect on it and say that's
what was going on
um she dropped out of school in the
eighth grade
barely passed the eighth grade
and because of drugs and
I fortunately had a gift and so I put
myself I was motivated and driven and I
got myself into gifted programs in Miami
um when I was 14 I went to the Center
for expressive Arts
and then at 15 I was a junior in high
school because I started school a year
early
and I went to the Performing and Visual
Arts Center which was very competitive
and very difficult to get into
and if I had stayed there for two years
and finished school in in Miami I would
have probably had a portfolio that could
have gotten me into a private art school
or something like that
but they built the police station there
and we had to move so
um we moved into my father's
girlfriend's house before we moved back
to Jacksonville
and it turned out that her name was
Janine too and my mom tells me you know
guess what her name's Janine too
well years later I found out my mom was
pregnant with me when my dad started
seeing her they had split up for about a
year and a half
and she decided to name me after my
dad's girlfriend
so I didn't learn that for many years
after
even learning she existed
but her giving us her home to live in
was the beginning of me opening up to
getting to know my father a little
better and after open heart surgery he
became less of an angry man he drank
less
um
and
I got to know a good human being later
on in life
meanwhile
um
we lived in her house for about a month
and then we moved back to Jacksonville
and we lived in the house we lived in
before we left Jacksonville and that's
where my brother started to get really
crazy
he was
he would drink at least a gallon of
vodka a day plus whatever else he could
get his hands on and he was scary and
violent and gay which I had no problem
with but he was flaming gay and I can
remember coming home from the library
because I would go to the library to
escape my family
and walking into the house and he's
naked in the living room with his
boyfriend on the couch or whoever he's
with at the time and that kind of thing
was normal I mean and our house was
filthy with cockroaches everywhere in
the kitchen because he would never clean
I was the only one who would clean
anything
we had double bolt locks on all of our
bedroom doors to protect us from my
brother's Rants and Raves when he would
break our stuff and steal our stuff
there were a few weeks where my mom
didn't buy food at all longer than that
and all we had to eat was rice or grits
with no salt or pepper I learned how to
just use herbs and water to make
something to eat
and then I won an art contest
um and I got two hundred dollars and I
started my first bank account
and so at that point my dad would wire
me a little money and I could go buy
food canned food and eggs and hide them
under my bed so I had food
at that point I graduated from high
school when I was 17 and I went to
Junior College for a short time and then
I went to the University of Georgia for
a short time
and then I went to the University of
Florida where I got my degree in Fine
Art and was
known in my art community there you know
um
so that was a good time in my life
because
um I had success as an artist and people
knew who I was and admired my talent
which I wasn't used to
and
then after college I kind of floundered
around for a while before I met my
ex-husband
and I guess he kind of Saved Me from
floundering around
and so six months into our relationship
we went to California for a trip to he
had friends here
would have helped us relocate to Los
Angeles but John said no he didn't want
to come to California he loved Florida
and I accepted that and ended up
marrying him anyway
maybe the reason why I married him
though was because a few days after we
came back from California on January 8
1992.
a police officer
a mental health worker and a social
worker came to our house
and knocked on the door and they came
and told me that my brother was in jail
for murdering my mom
and
my jaw dropped I cracked a few jokes
because that's how I deal with trauma
and I don't remember the rest of our
conversation but they asked if I was
okay
and I said yes and the reason I know
this is because years later after I left
my ex-husband I went back to Gainesville
and I ended up with the same mental
health counselor who had come to my
house that day who I had reached out for
for counseling after I left my
ex-husband and she reminded me of what
had happened that day
and so I told him everything was fine
and they left and when they were going
to their car they heard a blood curdling
scream from me
coming out of the house and I had
completely forgotten about that
um
so my sister was in Texas
and she was a drug addict and homeless
and on and off and
you know my mom helped both of them she
never helped me I was the one who was
able capable
um
and so she couldn't help
so my ex-husband and some of his friends
went with me to clean my mom's house in
St Petersburg Florida when she died
the way she died
my brother had a
male partner lover I guess who was
living in the house who was not mentally
competent and had been in and out of
mental institutions from what I was told
by a detective
he had tried to eat razor blades commit
suicide
um he just was not stable and not very
intelligent
and he was penned with the murderer my
brother got off on lack of evidence
but they're pretty sure my brother did
it and my brother was brilliant I mean
he also gave many many AIDS on purpose
and may have killed his lover before he
died in 2000 from AIDS
his lover also had AIDS that can never
be proven but he was very scary growing
up so he was definitely a psychopath
and psychopaths are often brilliant
which he was before the drugs and the
alcohol
so uh supposedly he killed her for three
thousand dollars of insurance money I
imagine that there were psychological
issues much deeper than that
and the way he killed her would probably
verify that fact
he strangled her with an electric cord
he stabbed her three or four times in
her neck
and then he put a six inch gash through
her stomach
later on years later I found out from my
sister who had gone to the detective
years later and it drilled him about
what had happened
she told me that she was alive for a
couple of hours after that that she was
allowed to she let her slowly bleed out
before she died
and she was not a good mom I mean I
hated my mom so I had to go through
grieving for someone that I never liked
that I felt relief was gone from my life
but I was the one left to pick up the
pieces to go through all the personal
effects to handle a garage sale so I
could get money to cremate her she
didn't want to be cremated but that's
all we could afford
and my sister came to the house while I
was doing the garage sale to find out
make sure I wasn't going to keep
anything or steal anything
meanwhile she wanted a box of papers and
I had not gone through them and so under
duress I gave it to her
I had a lady at the house at the time
helping me price antique glass
and she stole 80 from that lady's purse
and burned holes in my comforter I let
her spin One Night in my house and I
asked her not to smoke in the house and
she not only smoked but burned the floor
and the comforter and whatever she could
do
so
a few months later I find out that she
got a she got hold of my social security
number and my birth certificate and she
got a ID in my name and charged bank
accounts and credit accounts and stole a
rental car in my name
and a detective was looking for me my
father told me so my father faxed
pictures of me and my sister to the
detective
and verified that it was my sister
impersonating herself as me and she was
found in a methadone clinic in the
stolen car
I haven't I had not spoken to her for
over 20 years after that
and when I did you know I learned that
she'd spent many years homeless and
she's probably still homeless in
Oklahoma today
more than likely suffering schizophrenia
because she's had paranoid thoughts and
was hearing things
um and I haven't heard for it from her
in a few years because she keeps getting
her phone lost or stolen and
I just haven't heard from her so
um all I can do is pray for her and my
mom and my brother
and hope that they become better Souls
on the other side
and before my brother died of AIDS in
I was
I'd gone to see a guru woman in
Gainesville which is a very new age
community
I was learning Kundalini Yoga from some
American Sikhs and he turned me on to
this woman who was a guru named majaya
Sati bhagavati
and she had known Ram Das in the 60s
and she had an ashram in Florida called
Kashi ashram for the Indian city of the
dead it's in Sebastian Florida
and her mission was to help people who
were dying of AIDS die closer to God
and so I went to her darshan in
Gainesville in 1997 and many of her
devotees have AIDS
and I stood up in her darshan and I said
my brother has AIDS he murdered my mom
and I wish he would die already
and so she had me come up to her on her
podium
and sit in front of her and she said I'm
going to look into your eyes
and
you might get afraid but don't worry
everything will be okay
so I looked into her eyes she had big
glasses and her eyes looked like they
got bigger and kind of fogged over and
she asked me are you afraid and I said
no
touched my third eye she hugged me and
she gave me a rude Rock Show Indian
prayer bead and her business card and
told me to come see her
well three years later when my brother
was close to death and my stepmother had
encouraged me to see him before he died
I had not spoken to him since this had
happened
I did not go to the court proceedings I
did not want to see the pictures
but I did go see him before he died and
I took him to see marjaya and it took a
day and a half to get him to the other
side of Florida which should have taken
an hour and a half
because AIDS is a horrific disease and
he was degenerating and he could barely
move
mucus coming out of his nose just just
it was all he could do to just stay
awake
I took him to a state park bathroom and
a couple of hours waiting for him I had
someone go look in there make sure he
wasn't dead and he had fallen asleep on
on on the toilet so that's part of why
it took so long to get him there so he
wasn't able to meet majaya but she had
prayer prayed on a set of rude rockship
beats for him
and she'd offered to give him Refuge
there they have some of the
state-of-the-art doctors for AIDS
in Sebastian Florida which she has
organized
and
he refused
he couldn't believe that I had done this
for him
and so I took him back to Clearwater and
a couple of days later he collapsed and
his heart never resuscitated at the
hospital
so three days before he died in hospice
I went and saw him and I forgave him
it was the beginning of forgiving
because it's a really hard thing to do
but that started me on a journey to
Healing
and it's been many years and a lot of
work
I forgive my mother my brother my sister
my dad
his husband myself
I think the hardest is learning to
forgive yourself
but if you anyone who's suffering trauma
can do that they will find their way to
Healing
you have to learn to love yourself no
matter what
pain you've been through
it's not your fault even if you make a
bad decisions something LED you to meet
bad decisions
childhood trauma is lifelong
that today I am disabled from
post-traumatic stress disorder and I'm
bipolar
I'm hypomanic I'm not psychotically
but PTSD is
a really hard thing to live with
I work really hard with my diet and
getting enough sleep and exercise to be
as stable as I possibly can
and that and learning to love myself and
forgive myself
is helping tremendously
so
I can say I'm not a victim of domestic
violence I'm a survivor
were there things your brother went
through as a child that you think may
have led him down that path
I had a therapist for four and a half
years when I was married
I had a nervous breakdown after a year
and a half after what happened when my
brother died
and I was an abusive relationship with
my ex-husband
and
we came to the conclusion that it's
possible that there was an incestuous
relationship between my mom and my
brother
I don't know
um but they were unusually close
and she liked him being dependent on him
because she needed that she needed that
company that person close to her
depending on her yes and maybe that's
why he murdered her
because he didn't know how else to
Express
his frustration and he was already you
know mentally unstable
and if you believe in demonic entities
if you believe that can happen to people
who open themselves with lots of drugs
and stuff then maybe my brother was
possessed
what makes people evil what makes people
demonic or do horrific things
I mean they've got to be lost
spiritually
so I I I that's all I can think is
something
maybe too intimate happen between them
when he was very young
and my my father was very
angry and aggressive and my brother was
more effeminate my father beat up my
brother when he was 12 years old he was
molested by his bus driver at his
private school
and my father handled it by beating up
my brother and blaming him for letting
it happen
I remember that fight I was like six
years old and he threw him up against an
open dishwasher in the kitchen
and my dad was very scary when he was
angry he was had a lot of intensity as a
person
so that was obviously going to be
traumatic for my brother
I so I don't know maybe it's a
combination of all of those things
yeah
other than that I just don't have an
answer
it's a lot of family baggage to go
through yeah yeah
fortunately I'm working a trade with a
hypnotherapist she's helping me some
to go through past life stuff and maybe
that'll help me with current life trauma
I'll take whatever trauma whatever
therapy I get that can come my way I've
you know
if you find it's helpful yes absolutely
therapy is very helpful
you know
um
I think it should be more accessible to
more people you know
um I have disability and I have a
psychiatrist but getting a therapist
They Don't Really provide that you have
to pay for that
and it should be that way we'd have a
much more stable world if we could get
free and accessible mental health care
to people
but then we also just need food and
housing for people
that helps a lot too
I know it's not saying much but but you
seem much more mentally stable than your
siblings
yes and I wonder if if you're
work as an artist yes helped my my my
gift and my I wanted to be a famous
artist now I'm glad I'm maybe glad I'm
not famous because it's a lot of
responsibility to be famous
I hope one day I can be more successful
at it
um but
I mastered photo realism at the age of
16.
as a senior in high school
my high school teacher gave me a project
to I did the collage a photo of
photographs that I put together and she
told me to draw the line so close
together that you can't tell one line
from the other in black ebony pencil and
five and a half weeks later I produced
my first truly photo realistic drawing
so
um
my talent was my Saving Grace
you know I probably would have been
better off financially if I'd become a
psychologist or
there could have been many other things
that I could have done in life and been
more successful but
the Arts food for your soul
and I recommend anyone to take up
creative Endeavors for therapy yes I
think the world is saved from having too
many crazy people by
people's art yes and you know taking
away art and so many of us would be
totally crazy if we didn't have it many
of us many of us
many the ones who were lucky enough to
have the Arts are that's why they're not
crazy that's exactly right and we've got
to get them reinstated in the schools
physical education and and and the Arts
are crucial to a person's physical and
spiritual and intellectual development
so
yeah more more more therapy and more art
that's what our society needs exactly I
agree completely absolutely
I'm glad you're doing better now
you know it's a struggle you know it's
life and
um
you know when you are a person who
suffered trauma you tend to surround
yourself with people who've suffer
trauma people who haven't suffered
trauma don't understand
you're scary for people
so you know I tend to have people in my
life that also have a lot of trauma
and um
sometimes I'm always the one trying to
raise people up you know but I also have
my my issues with depression and
not the Mania so much
um a I'm older gone through menopause
that helped the hyperactivity really I'm
hyperactive and you know I have a genius
level Talent so that'll make you what
psychiatrists will call bipolar but I've
never been a danger to myself or anyone
else I've never been violent I've never
gone on shopping sprees for with money I
don't have or you know I've never done
any of those kind of things that are
typical of bipolar people that's why I
say I'm hypomanic
um
but
I I get enough sleep it's important to
get enough sleep if you're bipolar even
if you can't sleep at four o'clock in
the morning stay in bed
and let your mind rest make sure you do
that for eight hours every night at
least take naps they help too with
stress do you think the bipolar
Tendencies you've picked up are
inherited or they might be stress
induced probably trauma induced that's
what I was wondering yeah
I mean I don't know if my mom was
bipolar or maybe she had borderline
personality disorder
you know she
says we come from French royalty well
what that means is we come from
inbredding imbrity
so with inbreeding comes mental
instability
and some get it and some don't some get
the genius some get the crazy
you know
sometimes you get a little bit of both
probably most of the time but I think
having a spiritual base
and a connection to your higher power
however you want to Define that
is huge in finding grounding and
um
hope you have to have faith
to have hope yeah Hope's important and
and you gotta have
hope and fate
in order to heal
you know and you have to embrace love
for yourself and for others even the
people that hurt you the most you have
to extend love to them because it's the
only way you can change
the the the lower frequencies
that cause people to act so horribly in
the first place
if you're at a higher level if you're
living in love
you raise the vibration of the people
around you
it's not easy
but
it can be done
and you can do it for yourself most of
all yeah that's that's the lesson to
learn from all that yes is you're doing
it for yourself yes and you help
everyone else around you yes absolutely
everyone everyone
you help everyone when you do it for
yourself
and Mark if you want more stories in the
future I've got a lot more stories
I think I think maybe just hit the ice
for you there yeah really it is the tip
of the iceberg yes all right Janine
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome thank you for giving me
the opportunity this is beautiful things
you shared at the end too thank you we
want people to have hope it isn't all
despairing trauma can lead to healing
and empowerment
so
anyone who's suffering trauma just
remember
if you can get to a place of loving
yourself forgiving yourself and loving
those and forgiving those who hurt you
the most you will experience a sense of
empowerment
from that
exercise
absolutely it's a gift to yourself and
to the other people who probably need it
desperately they're hurting or else they
wouldn't have hurt other people
beautiful talk thank you